lefties have struggled against aaron
let's hope that continues tonight
three and two or three era last time out
he threw his change up 31.9 percent of
the time
trade turret has hit at 16 consecutive
games look at his
his numbers are 34 for 67. that's a 507
clip
quick and a miss back-to-back curveballs
one out here in the first inning what do
you think the last time trey turner saw
three pitches and struck out
and it'll bring up howie kendrick 0-2
pitch swing in the miss
1-2-3 top of the first inning for aaron
nola
11 pitches and patrick corbin 10 career
starts against the phillies five and two
and we told you about his last start
against the fills 96 pitches [ __ ] well
four-seam fastball slider change
two-seam fastball occasional curve
that'll bring up bryce harper line
drives up the middle and
good start bryce two out single for
bryce his seventh hit against corbin
they had a base hitting the walk and all
of a sudden
you know they're in business yeah and
you know with the way segura swing in
the bat
you like your chances here with two outs
breaking ball segura went down to get it
and now thames to get it patrick corbin
out of the inning single and a walk
two left
luis garcia 0-3 against him last week
he's going to go the other way
that's a fair ball into the corner up
with it gosling
gonna have to hustle he's in there and
for luis garcia that breaks about a
three-day over
so man in scoring position for the gnats
so here's michael taylor
[Applause]
strike three call the fastball in the
outside corner four strikeouts
for nola and now make some face juan
soto with two on and
two outs
quickly off the mound just takes it to
the bag himself
one unassisted that's a really good
pitching right there
no runs ahead two men left
he's determined to bun his roman quinn
cabrera a brilliant play to throw him
out
as dribble with the bare hand that was
nice
reese hoskins fly ball to adam eaton
first time
down the right field line eaton on the
run toward the corner
and he can't get it it's stuck off the
base of the wall mccutcheon the third
he'll be held there it's a double for
hoskins his ninth of the season
he moves into the top ten in that
category
and it's second and third with one out
here's harper infield is in
swing and a miss on a ball down and away
two down
big strikeout and what a time for
corbin's first
two outs here mccutchen at third base
reese hoskins at second
outfield playing jt slightly to pull as
corbin is ready at the bell
got him down and in beautifully done
strikeouts of harper
and real muto aaron's curveball has been
beautiful tonight swag and a miss
he threw a one curve ball after another
six strikeouts for nola
[Music]
because i mean those pitchers are
strikes for a long long time
and that's what garcia sees strike
strikes strike down below the knee
swing and miss fastball hit to the right
side and segora
will take care of michael taylor patrick
corbin faces alex baum the third baseman
number eight here in the lineup
pulls it well deep to left field soto's
going back
to the fence it is gone
alec balm his first citizens bank park
and the phillies take a one-nothing lead
near the bottom of the fifth inning
jt romuto will for the second
consecutive time come to the plate with
two men aboard
one and one the jt a run in on the homer
by boehm
and jt shoots and it's a right field to
face in hoskins around third heading for
home
eaton's throw will go to second it's two
nothing phillies rbi for jt
harper goes to third there's no text
necking right there
john that's a good here's the set in the
0-1
breaking ball pulling the ground diving
stop turner from a knee throw to second
out at second to end the inning what a
play by trey turner
diving stop to his right of the outfield
grass and pushed himself up to an e to
make a sidearm almost
whipping throw to garcia at second so to
put two men aboard with nobody out and
alec baum coming up bowm with a home run
his last time up
out toward right center field taylor on
the run he won't get it it's a one hop
off the scoreboard
jay bruce read it perfectly dede
gregorius slipped down now the throw to
the plate and he
is safe as the ball goes off beyond
gomes glove
i think dusty dusty was stopping jay
bruce but i think
because he was so close to dede thought
he was stopping him
he could have yeah here's andrew
mccutchen infield halfway in now with
one out
now get something here andrew don't miss
it
he didn't miss it he crushed it it's a
three-run home run
for andrew mccutchen and the phillies
are on top
six nothing aranola who has allowed just
two hits
and has struck out six
change up and that's another
you said that's the thing his last
downing good morning good afternoon
and go sit down and they're thinking
will i ever get another hit
the one two pitch he does he threw him
the curve ball he got him with something
off speed
eight strikeouts for nola and a one
two three seventh inning you have
reached the ninth inning
in philadelphia philly's six in the
nationals nothing so two outrunners in
scoring position
and adam eaton will be the batter
over to third base balm picks it and
hustles the throw over
just in time to get eaten and the ball
game is over the phillies have won four
straight against the nationals